bonsoir j'espère que vous regardez cette
vidéo très tard le soir que nous avons
joué à un jeu de medusa ce labyrinthe yo
tout le monde sait squeeze aujourd'hui
en s'auto sur mesac damas
j'adore genex j'ai bien mérité vous
aurez maintenant que c'est fait c'est
parti on est sûr d'une chose que je dis
donc c'est l'un des jeux les plus
téléchargés de visas c'est un jeu
d'horreur gratuit sur steam est alors
pourtant super bien fait s'est basé sur
la grèce antique sur les légendes et où
qu'avais je méconnais extrêmement peu
engageantes xv à vous mentir même
mythologie manière générale je suis une
merde père m'a dit qu'il avait de bonnes
nouvelles aujourd'hui mais n'a pas l'air
heureux il a dit que j'étais l'élu
j'étais celui qui devait servir le
temple en tant qu oracle
je ne me suis jamais senti à ma place
dans les cuisines mais maman ne m'a
jamais les séries avoir d'autres les
casseroles et les pots à longueur de
journée j'ai prié et dieu m'a répondu
pourquoi père n'est pas content pour moi
parce qu' un gros mot ce qui va te
couper la gueule voilà leur tuque t'aime
tu retournes ferté burger fdp
je suis père violent alors ça c'est
super joli [ __ ] et ce jeu est gratuit
si génial
waouh du coup on va dans les cuisines et
ça passera jobs simulator qu'on a déjà
fait deuxième note
aujourd'hui est le jour où elle m'a même
pour la première fois autant vers dit
que je ne pourrais plus l'appeler père
et que personne au temple dont on entend
parler de lui ou de maman il m'a dit que
les acolytes devraient arriver au lever
du soleil et que je ne devrais pas m'en
faire mais je m'inquiète
il ne m'a jamais fait ce magazine ok ok
bah c'est parti on va au temple un bon
gars et la percée transformant [ __ ] 0
au regard des gens il ya des gens hello
je suis une nouvelle raclée respectez
moi mes toiles je me fais moi un
sandwich tu fais une statue côté hyper
étrange bavarois acebo monga [ __ ]
super gros donc on va au temple c'est
parti ok on est donc autant on est tous
contempler y allez les mecs qui vont pas
tarder à arriver
voilà ce que j'ai retenu c'est très très
beau ça aussi ça ferait un très bon soit
1 ça vous dirait que nos stars ensemble
ici eh ben ça arrivera jamais le
seigneur des profondeurs cache beaucoup
de secrets bas il est où il est là cette
porte s'est fermée hier premier secret
il a caché la clé voilà à une deuxième
note au final je ne vais pas devenir un
oracle père est venu avec des hommes et
à tuer les prêtres l'un de ses amis a
été poignardée j'ai crié vers m'a giflé
pour que je me taise
il ne l'avait jamais frappé il monte
ensuite amené un autre droit dans le
temple ils m'ont enfermé ici avec
l'homme blessé son souffle et ray
elle avait fait un sont bizarres que
n'expire il a du sang partout sur ma
robe bleue celle que mère m'avait offert
l'été dernier je demande si ça partira à
la machine place à partir à cause de la
briser pas de machine et à l'époque mais
[ __ ] samba les couilles de ta robe et
des sports vainqueur train d'agoniser il
est ou alors comment son bail et chaîne
tout simplement on va tirer la chaîne et
ça va s'ouvrir
voilà ta mère jallet entourage avait une
super vie devant moi tu viens tu niques
tout avec tes hommes là on descend à
temps ils peuvent même temps non à moi
je suis en mode sur les lorrains ont pas
se mentir mais c'est super bien fait
j'adore ça change énormément touché
d'europe qu'on a fait ce choix partir
d'ici où c'est les couloirs sombres et
humides dans lequel va mourir on bat
écoute on va avancer
ona note sur ce baril de mon vin c'est
une note d'arc à spa dahli on a cette
fois j'ai encore quelques amis dont la
jeune prêt qui a promis de m'aider on va
leur tendre une embuscade dans les
jardins et la tenir à l'écart des salles
doigts du off en toc est ok no comprendo
mais où la cacher ils achèteront partout
dans le visage elle ne sera pas en
sécurité près de l'eau comme un pauvre
type pourquoi as-tu temps ressemble à ta
mère ou alors à continuer à cette note
était très charmante
on est en paix elle est simple si on
voit que dalle mon gas a buzzé le noir
le plus total par la cua une corde rien
n'impose bcba oui une note dû à
l'épidémie qui touche desservant l'est
des catacombes a dû être fermé est mise
en quarantaine ou d'accords du couffo
payet la barre glacée sur ma voiture de
mon chouchou qui a muté un sa maladie
est due à des zombies à l'époque en vrai
au mon dieu qu'est ce que c'est moi
c'est une torche
oh oui allez on allume hôpital est un
monstre mais qu'il ya à mons était
sérieux déconne pas à tort cela on bat
les couilles le fossé alors frappeurs
mais oui c'est sûr j'ai dû feu tu as
rien faire ok les documents on va
essayer documents - moi ce qui
m'intéresse à serment de m'enfuir a
c'est quoi ce bordel mec c'est quoi ça
une pomme et avait des gens ici il ya
des gens ici
cette pommade d'avant-hier dash est
revenu au point de départ je suis revenu
aux [ __ ] de points n'est pas mais je
suis né merde en mon dieu un arc et des
flèches
on s'en souvient
ces vertus on coince ça alors là on va
vraiment pouvoir avoir calmement mais
flèche mon gars on va affronter des
morros qui suit à faire j'ai trouvé un
moyen de la cacher de tous
ok de gros pétards cassé mon père c'est
lui qui m'a enfermé ici et qui a
compromis le fait que j'allais devenir
une aura qui dit qu'il espère que je
comprendrais qu'il a fait ça pour me
protéger je n'aurais jamais dû la gifle
est comme ça mais son cri aurait pu tout
faire foirer l'avant de timéo c'était
quelque chose de très difficile pour
chacun d'entre nous une petite gifle
derrière comparaison mais rassure-toi
rassure toi je peux encore entendre son
rire très mignon bientôt quoi ils seront
arrêtés de chercher je la ferai sourire
comme il se doit au caire casbah l'or a
casté ou espère quoi pas trouvé sur ta
carcasse au en hauteur kasri la grotte
on va le trouver [ __ ]
le problème c'est qu'il ya un bug et
j'arrive pas à sortir ma torche du coup
je suis buzz est belle et la plus débile
à on va aller par la barca c'est quoi
cette barre à mon avis l'arrière du café
avec l'arc c'est ça attention le style
iphone qui donne à la sas a fait pas
plaisir va ressortir la tâche va pas se
mentir la torche la torche la torche
[ __ ] make way n'arrête pas les a
lâchés mais c'est complètement coincé
j'ai trop peur mais qui trop peur ok ok
ok je me marre je marche je marche je
marque moins de mourir je veux pas votre
sale maladie drâa qui se tient mais non
n'était pas mais qu on va où on va tout
droit on va à droite dans l'endroit où
mille gens sont morts alors à l'endroit
où les gens sont morts décourager on est
brave va pas se mentir pourquoi mon
écurie bas comme ça mais c'est un mec
mais tu fais quoi ici mes défauts que
mère je me barre même si la torche étage
parce qu'il aime courir après le fils de
chien assez marrant là c'est pas des
piles qu'il faut trouver ces des torches
c'est trop bien voilà parenthèse fermée
holla holla holla l'on descend on
s'enfonce dans les profondeurs on va
encore plus mourir là on est bien entre
ces deux murs au pire on sent l'arc
arrow in the eye au shit ok une de as if
you prefer je sais pas ce que c'est
c'est eh ben moi mais c'est super chiant
la soie dans uncharted agri qui fait
tout péter pour tous les trésors que
dans cette question pital au bar tué à
l'aube
c'est normal c'est mickael vous savez le
niveau de la seine a monté voilà ça crée
des bons c'est du sang c'est normal
c'est normal ça je saurai pas justifiée
mais c'est normal vous ne vous paniquez
pas fait récupérer vous fait paniquer si
tu as quoi ça oh oh non ça y est ça y
est il fallait bien un jour qu'on en
croise un jeu sans larmes en garde
j'ai largué large est large et large et
la voyez là bas mais qui non non non non
non non non accroupis toi vie d'un
groupe doit vite s'est passé s'est passé
je fêterai pourquoi suis je n'ai pas
hâte en rien à un autre non c'est bon
c'est lui qui craquent iile aidés
guerrab je les croise une fois sur maui
jim insulté puisque j'ai tué plein de
fric bastion smara bien je peux pas
passer ici c'est bloqué c'est comme s'il
avait fait une sorte de barrage si je
peux pas sauter m'accroupir ah voila
voila voila c'est rassurant hélas la
torche
oui très très bien très très bien on est
bien et merde comme on passe ce truc
doit s'ouvrir ce truc souffre c'est sûr
et 2ème en une chaîne un truc et par la
chaîne s'il vous plaît elle est pas
loyal mons non il n'aurait pas fait ça
non c'est bon faut juste passer la
[ __ ] j'avais peur qu'on continue ok on
est pas mal
oh non non non non non non tu es sérieux
on bâille couche d'atomes cheikh mon arc
dans l'arc sans marc sens large sur
l'arc sans relâche world heart soir
d'arte online m'a tuer mais il mange mon
canal s'est amusé avec ta ps c'est une
la bd je suis choqué on va les coudes on
y retourne parce qu'on va se faire c'est
f3 pour sortir l'arcsi vient d'asie via
mais pourquoi il sort pas là mais ça
mais c'est mellick on dirait moi
l'égalité cbl à tirer des flèches vas-y
bien vient maintenant via au wat choc
wadja aignan paquin gaz beach cierges
fait l'amour à tout jadhav a tenté ce
mais comment d'avoir une calvitie les
parcs ou d'avoir des chaussures les
faits ce qu a eu un petit passage secret
juste la regarde et on s'enfonce encore
plus c'est la fumée plus tard j'en ai
marre j'en ai marre vous êtes sûr de
train fantôme un peu mal fait quand même
croyez moi si tu verras m'en vais là bas
à ok c'est là bas j'adore l'ambiance
[ __ ] ça change vachement des jeux où
ce avec une caméra en 2016 là on est
bien l'ancienne avec la sortie que mon
pote l'est moins c'est son visage ont
des cheveux sur les fesses et on reste
rowland fait pas [ __ ] bruit fait
confiance à l'expert en art chinois ye
note à lyon la dernière note
il ya de la fièvre je l'entends tous et
se retourner et pleuré pendant que la
chanson le manche l'hôte est parti pour
aller chercher son maître et n'est
jamais revenu moi je n'ai pas de fief du
tout je suis aussi froid que le monde
qui m'entoure aussi froid que
l'obscurité dans ces tunnels
je fais partie d'ici maintenant oui
c'est vrai allez on va et au studio avec
une flèche entre deux yeux puis on va
passer à la suite [ __ ] la flèche la
flèche
il est où il ya quoi y'a quoi non non
non
what
c'est ça la fin c'est ça la chute même
moi je n'ai pas de fièvre donc je survis
mais je suis aussi froide que ces
tunnels avant [ __ ] quelle chute mais
[ __ ] de trophées plantes
il ya des choses qui a comme cette vidéo
sur méduses labyrinthe une espagnole de
cerveau appelée moi en tout cas j'ai
bien aimé mais on voit que le jeu n'est
pas finie en fait j'ai lu que ça devait
faire partie d'un jeu bien plus gros que
ça toujours ménages 3 qui doit commencer
à développer et c est qu ils ont fait un
petit truc avec mais voilà on peut le
voir cette fin là aucun butin de sens
c'est comme ça révèle afin d' inception
et à la fin c'était oui toi aussi tu
rêve chaque nuit a plus sa 9e [ __ ] de
rien dire voilà c'était une prochaine
version regarder portez vous bien jo de
bombes
pis
oh